yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
trolls the latest film from DreamWorks
Animation takes us on a journey through
the world of these all hugging all
singing and all dancing cute little
shiny happy creatures as they try to
avoid being captured by the extremely
gloomy ogre like bergens you can only
experience happiness by gobbling up
trolls the story is quite
straightforward and follows an odd
couple
the always cheery and optimistic puppy
and the downbeat and ever anxious branch
as they somewhat reluctantly set out
together to save their fellow brightly
coloured beings from ending up in the
Bergen stomachs with pitch-perfect
Anna Kendrick voicing poppy Justin
Timberlake playing branch and new girl
Zooey Deschanel as the Bergen scullery
maid Bridget the filmmakers would have
been mad not to make the most of their
cast singing talents so you can expect
plenty of musical scenes and song and
dance numbers the majority of which fit
pretty nicely within the tale being told
the toys the movies based on were
actually popular at various points in
the 1960s through to the 90s so
fittingly the soundtrack is mostly
filled with tunes from those eras
including some plastic disco tracks and
power ballads as well as some new pop
songs if you like many of the songs
which the cast covers then you'll likely
find yourself in a good mood and the
right place to enjoy the movie overall
but it's the animation where the film
really shines there's an incredible
tactile textured quality to the whole
film and particularly the trolls
themselves directors Mike Mitchell and
Walt Dohrn and their animators have
really outdone themselves capturing the
fealty fuzziness of the trolls in their
world which is essentially a crazy blast
of colours and glitter and there's an
especially lovely sequence where poppy
wanders through the forest and comes
across all sorts of weird beasts and
plant life sure the story and characters
don't have the complexity or the wide
range of pop culture Easter eggs we get
from the likes of Pixar or the best of
Disney or dreamworks itself and it's
clear where Jonathan Abel and Glenn
Berger screenplay is going from the
start and yes the movie does put its
message front and center on several
occasions still they were seeing
characters like these before and the
story certainly borrows the likes of The
Hobbit Cinderella and Serrano de
Bergerac or if you prefer Roxane the
movie is perfectly enjoyable sweet and
decent firm that moves along at a good
pace and knows to quit by the 90 minute
mark while it's still ahead mink knows
trolls is squirrely aimed at younger
kids but there are some adult hinged
moments and the quality of the animation
the music and some of its humor means it
does have potential for adult audiences
too and of course it's entirely possible
some grown-ups may identify with aspects
of branches less than rosy attitude to
life which while it makes him an outlier
among his joy-filled fellow trolls acts
as a nice counterbalance to the trolls
never-ending wildly enthusiastic nature
which some adults might find a little
jarring otherwise to sum up trolls
creates a beautifully textured fuzzy
world packed with color and sparkle the
movies clear storyline and simple
message wrapped up in bright packaging
makes it ideal for younger kids and
while it's unlikely to make your list of
unforgettable films it will likely keep
you indefinitely any young ones
entertained while you're watching so I'm
giving trolls 3 out of 5 flicks now are
you looking forward to the movie trolls
or if you've seen it what did you think
and what are your favorite animations
this year so far let me know in the
comments below
coming up I'll be reviewing sci-fi flick
arrival and I'll also be making videos
on a TV show quest world and Disney's
Moana if you enjoyed this video do
please share it and subscribe for more
movie reviews and crazy movie and TV
facts click the links here to check
those out thanks for watching and see
you next time you'll be going we'll be
lovers